qué hay detrás de esta maniobra de Rusia
a las puertas del invierno en Europa
desde el punto de vista militar
aún sin haber pues sin sentirse sin
estar el invierno todavía
es insostenible la defensa de la margen
oeste del río neper y es ahí donde está
gerson y el territorio que con la el
abandono de jerson podemos asumir que
los rusos van a abandonar eventualmente
todas sus posiciones al oeste del río
ñéper y crear Pues el río ñaper como una
larga línea defensiva ya hemos escuchado
como el Grupo Mercenario Wagner ruso
pues está creando una línea defensiva
Wagner por dugansk en la zona del Don
Bass Pues usarán el río para ello y
demuestra que simplemente
las fuerzas rusas que entraron Pues con
tanto poder en febrero de este año está
muy mermadas muy debilitadas y los
ucranianos Pues están en un período
Llano a la defensiva aquí sino en la
ofensiva
Ucrania dice que no van a hablar de una
retirada de Rusia de ejercer hasta que
su bandera vuelva a ondear sobre la
ciudad de hecho el presidente Celeste
acaba de comentar que se van a mover con
cuidado es esto una victoria irá
esperanzas a Ucrania en el conflicto sí
Y claro no quiere decir no sabemos
cuánto tiempo va a durar el general
Hutch americano retirado que fue
Comandante el ejército americano en
Europa creo que llegó a decir que
podrían los ucranianos pues liberar los
territorios invadidos este año para
fines de este año no sé si eso será
posible pero ciertamente que en la
intención de Ucrania es eventualmente
liberar a crimea y claro los territorios
que fueron invadidos este año incluyendo
la costa del mar de azoff y ahí tiene
sitios icónicos como Mario Paul Está
también Benito Paul y claro la zona del
Don vaso O sea que la ofensivo ucraniana
ahora mismo están presionando por gerson
pero también en el norte
donde precisamente los rusos tratan de
hacer avances pero se han quejado sus
tropas de que tiene malos generales y en
una un ataque ruso reciente a una Villa
en el don vas creo que fue les mataron
los ucranianos a 500 de sus tropas pero
la guerra Sigue Sí en línea con lo que
usted comenta se puede esperar otra
retirada de este tipo en algún punto en
concreto de Ucrania de Ucrania ocupada
por parte de Rusia podría ocurrir aquí
especulando mapas distribuidos en en
Twitter por el Ministerio de defensa
británico
demuestran o muestran que hay una fuerte
actividad partisana guerrillero
ucraniana en la zona entre Mario Paul y
la Península crimea por melitopol por
expediansk Entonces yo especulando Qué
pasa si los ucranianos logran cruzar el
río ñé pero se rompen las defensas rusas
a lo largo de todo el río ñaper y
entonces enlazan con los partisanos y
rápidamente capturan pues si no Mario
Paul emelitó Paul es verdians y cortan
la comunicación terrestre de los rusos
con crimea crimea con el don Bass y hay
otra cosa que el puente atacado ruso
sobre el estrecho de kers pues no será
reparado a corto plazo quizá creo que en
2023 quedará completamente reparado y
eso limita el flujo de refuerzos rusos
desde la Rusia continental vamos a decir
al este del estrecho de kers acrimea y
de allí a gerson quizá por eso se están
retirando porque no están recibiendo el
número suficiente suministros a través
de ese puente averiado